[Musique]
et
une
[Musique]
alors oui là-bas pitot oui mais voilà
brieuc lorient ma nation
[Musique]
les actifs rti est des polonais
canale et des castings around town
paypal et loyaux services
les causes et de fans la forme de west
bank maroc s'est clôt cette soudaine
line qui semblait apaisée comme choriste
[Musique]
j'ai visité deux camps quand j'étais
là-bas le premier c'était le camp de
malakal donc malakal c'était une des
deuxième troisième plus grosse ville du
soudan du sud et il faut savoir qu'en
fait le gouvernement un jour est arrivé
et a commencé à tirer sur tout le monde
donc tout le monde fuit et a couru vers
le camp des casques bleus la base
militaire des casques bleus et s'est
réfugié dans cette base militaire
évidemment les casques bleus ne
pouvaient pas les refuser donc les ont
défendus et les ont protégés mais en
fait ils sont restés ils ont dit non
mais nous on ne bouge pas ah bah ils ont
peur donc ils préfèrent rester dans ce
camp dans les conditions dans lesquelles
ils sont plutôt que de revenir dans
leurs anciennes maisons serbes détruite
mais même en étant détruits croyez moi
les tôles dans laquelle ils vivent
sont moins confort que dans leurs
maisons détruites de malakal qui peuvent
reconstruire
le problème c'est que dans ces villages
et dans ces villes il ya le gouvernement
qui
et installer gouvernement qui très peu
de temps avant les massacrait et qu'il
aurait aujourd'hui leur divin c'est bon
c'est la paix vous pouvez revenir sauf
que ces gens là n'ont absolument pas
confiance dans le gouvernement et ce
disque i vous revenir que les aides
internationales vont partir et que là le
gouvernement va re les massacrer le
deuxième camp qui a bourges qui est
beaucoup plus dans la nature pour le
coup c'est ce fameux camp où j'ai dû
faire deux heures de bateau quatre
heures de tracteur et est encore de la
voiture et on est vraiment perdu ou
oublié de rien il faut savoir c'est un
donc un camp qui est acquis à 2 de
saison c'est la saison des pluies ou du
coup on se retrouve avec une énorme
étant un énorme étant dos ce qui était
le cas quand une fille était ce qui est
pratique pour les ong qui peuvent aller
chercher de l'eau la filtrer pour allart
donner au peuple ce qui permet de faire
des cultures ce qui permet de l'ordre de
faire manger les bêtes etc etc
mais il faut savoir que ce qui va
arriver bientôt il ya une énorme saison
sèche et la saison sèche classe et 45
degrés il n'y a rien rien rien et pour
aller chercher de l'eau faut faire
quatre heures pour à léonie leblanc
chercher remplir des camions d'eau et
pouvoir les a menés jusque là voilà le
la réalité de la situation aujourd'hui
là bas donc du coup on se retrouve dans
des dans des camps de déplacés qui sont
complètement en perfusion permanente
avec les ong
à tel point que comme ça fait des années
que les ong sont là parce qu'elle était
là aussi pendant la guerre elles sont là
depuis la guerre civile et que le
gouvernement est complètement absent et
que eux ces guerres et argent et ces
mêmes français même pas s'ils vivent là
quoi vous voyez le genre de profil de
gouvernement à tel point que les
habitants pensent que les ong c'est
quelque chose de normal en fait c'est ça
fait partie de leur vie de pays que
c'est presque comme si c'était des
ministères le ministère de la santé de
l'éducation c'était l'objectif et
l'éducation telles ong qui fait la santé
telles ong qui fait si qui fait ça etc
du coup quand on leur annonce que l'omg
va partir parce qu'il ya plus d'argent
pour financer la mission il ya vraiment
une incompréhension il ya une colère en
fait il mais pourquoi vous partez mais
vous vous rendez compte vous allez nous
laisser on a pu avoir accès à l'eau
potable on va pu avoir accès à l'hygiène
à l'éducation
on leur dit oui on sait mais on ne peut
pas faire plus on n'a pas de sous pas ce
que ces ong dépendent de dons et du coup
elles doivent partir et on laisse ces
populations dans perdu en fait
[Musique]